it's not that the election was rigged
per se by the states
or the vote counters or mail-in ballots
it's that it was essentially rigged by
cnn
los angeles times new york times most
all
legacy and mainstream media and then
big tech and you know all the googles
and the and
twitter and all that all that it was
rigged by them
essentially and if you really think
about it it's not much hyperbole
all right let's talk about the election
a little bit i'm just giving you like
the whole landscape of all the craziness
of the world the election
where he at at this point apparently joe
biden is the president-elect
i i don't think uh you voted for joe
biden did you
did you officially announce who you
voted for i know where where you're at
politically but did you actually say it
on your show
but i would definitely vote for trump
over over by
yeah um the
the the interesting take on it which
isn't
you know insanely impressive in terms of
the math but uh
sort of what ben shapiro has always been
talking about for the last several weeks
which is it's not that the election
was rigged per se by
the states or the vote counters or
mail-in ballots it's that it was
essentially rigged by
cnn los angeles times new york times
most all legacy and mainstream media and
then big tech you know all the googles
and that
and and twitter and all that all that it
was rigged by them
essentially and if you really think
about it it's not much hyperbole
i mean if you think about just the
hunter biden story
as an example and you go okay and forget
it's hunter biden and forget what the
allegations are and forget anything
let's just be generic
there's a story it's a credible story
and it would hurt one candidate
and i don't know if that means three
points or seven points or i don't know
what it would translate into
but it would definitely be damaging to
one of the candidates so
in our in our hypothetical world there's
a candidate
and b candidate and b candidate would
definitely be hurt by a story
that comes out several days before
the big election and then
all the legacy news organizations and
then
and then silicon valley they all
conspire
to crush a story and are saying things
like russian disinformation or there's
no proof whatsoever
so that story never comes out well
i would argue that that is tampering
with the election
it's certainly affecting the election i
mean i guess if you say
what's the definition of tampering with
an election i guess the definition would
be
affecting the election one way or the
other for this candidate or that
candidate
so they're all on board to do this
they always do this thing it's funny
when the
smartest people in the world the silicon
valley guys go
oh yeah we didn't know what was going on
with that thing we
we made a mistake we're gonna get better
processes we should have looked at that
before
right you didn't know huh and and
by the way it's pretty simple uh they
found a laptop had a bunch of
information on it
might you have some follow-up questions
or you just announced that's
russian disinformation so you had a
whole
group of people when i say a group i
mean
most 90 of the media essentially
running interference for one of the
candidates and
and all the way through just you know
the covet vaccines never going to come
out before the end of the year etc
on every single story uh yeah that's
going to translate into a few points
and that is that is the tampering do you
think there's
anything left at this point in terms of
mainstream media
like i think if if my one takeaway
probably of the year
beyond lockdowns and the way we give up
freedoms and all that but like my one
sort of tangible takeaway is that there
is simply nothing left in mainstream
media that doesn't mean that a hundred
percent
of reporters are all [ __ ] artists
but i think the way they treated the
hunter
by it and story then the way we were
immediately told not to look at anything
related
to election fraud and if we did we're
we're basically alex jones and
everything else
like to me there's nothing left you know
washington post
new york times cnn like it's just done
am i am i over the top
well there's something left but the
question is
is what did they do to their brand
so if you think about think about
what the oscars means in 2021
versus the oscars from our childhood it
was
first off it was appointment viewing get
the whole family
see who the best picture of the year who
got the and the best picture of the year
got that was the best picture of the
year you know i mean
we didn't argue about it and we didn't
think there was any politics involved
and it just
was you know and by the way you know
when you look at the
ratings for these shows you realize it
ain't
what it used to be by by a long shot and
and i'll give you a couple examples so
think about
the oscars think about the emmys think
think about how i did a little
experiment around here
i have young people who work for me i
said uh if you heard a story out of cnn
five years ago
what would you have thought and they
went i would have believed it and i'd
say
what do you think now and they go uh i'd
have to go look into it so
cnn new york times all the entities you
mentioned
but also oscars emmys uh
maybe the nba uh rotten tomatoes yeah
you know you see hillbilly elegy oh it's
24
with the critics but 88 with the people
oh what a shocker you know
no safe spaces is i don't know 44
with the critics and 90 with the people
so so no we no longer have to go to we
don't have to find out what the critics
have to say
on uh rotten tomatoes because it's
skewed
everything is skewed and whoever wins
the oscars gonna be
you know oh he's the he's the black gay
teen who's struggling with his sexuality
okay i get it and and by the way when
you do that
you are shaking hands with the devil you
really are in terms of your brand
the oscars should have never let all
this super woke [ __ ] in
because once you announce
now need 50 people of color
nominated for the best actor it's over
it's over we stop
we stop we go were they the best actors
or is they just
meeting a quota by the way so they're
shooting themselves in the foot but the
best part of it is they decided to put
all these quotas in about you know skin
color and sexuality
and you know if you're a [ __ ] or you
have a lazy eye or whatever except they
said we're not going to do it for three
years
it's so important to solve racism and
sexism but
we still have some stuff in the can so
we've got to get that racist crap out of
the way
and we'll do it we'll do it in three
years you mentioned no safe spaces so
i'm sure most of my audience has seen it
already but when when you think back to
the project because you guys probably
you and dennis and the team probably
started working on this thing what like
four years ago maybe something like that
yeah when you think back to the project
i mean it basically everything and i'm
not just saying it because because we
both happen to be in it but everything
that no safe spaces is about
which in essence is that all of this
woke craziness
from the college campus is going to leak
into re into real society
it's what everyone sees now and we were
all told we were racists and bigots and
the rest of it for talking about it
are are you kind of are you like
impressed
that we kind of called it or are you
depressed that we kind of called it or
just is what it is because we called it
we all called it now
everyone knows that that is the the
stuff that is happening everywhere right
now
well first off how could it not like
what if
what if your kid leaves for college
and then every one of their professors
is a vegan and then
they're teaching classes on meat as
murder don't tell your
chef husband because he makes a
delectable wagyu
i think we have by the way did i hear
correctly on your podcast i think the
day or a
day or two after you came over here for
dinner i think you said it was the best
steak you ever had
it was man so so kudos to you
for uh living with that hey i handled
the steak you seriously i i was doing
the same oh damn you're right
i had a couple of scotches at that point
sorry dave you get all credit to dave
rubin for doing
doing the steak but um what the hell
were you talking about now i forgot
about it
that you send if you send your kids to
these schools they're being taught by oh
yeah
okay so everyone's a vegan and meat is
murder
uh how long before your kid starts
coming home for thanksgiving and saying
no thanks to the turkey because meat is
murder and then
when those kids in their vegan
environment get pushed out
into main street and madison avenue
and start showing up at corporations how
long before
they start judging people for eating a
ham sandwich
and how could it go any other way of
course it's going to go that way
i mean you get you go to this place
where a bunch of ideology is taught to
you
and then the construct or
or at least college is basically there
to i mean if you think about
what what is the what what is the
mission statement for
college well you go to this place for
four years
we teach you a bunch of stuff and then
you take that with you
into society right well we just thought
it was going to be a bunch of
engineering and calculus and
you know art history we didn't know it
was going to be an indoctrination to a
bunch of ideas
but it is and i would argue those ideas
are more powerful than
engineering are because you can't just
walk into your
new job at kinko's and start talking to
everyone about structural engineering or
shear loads or tension anchors or
something they're not going to it's not
going to take but if you start talking
to everyone
about your ideology then it's going to
spread and that's exactly where we're
living
if you're looking for more honest and
thoughtful conversations about comedy
instead of the non-stop yelling you get
everywhere else check out our comedy
playlist and if you want to watch
full interviews on a variety of topics
check out our full episode playlist
they're both
right over here and to get notified of
all future videos be sure to subscribe
and click the notification bell